that's our ticket home
[Music]
do not make me regret this
[Music]
and get that looper ready we don't have
much time
blooper you again
never mind looks sharp we're saving
[Music]
reality
what did you do to the zero point it
wasn't me
there was an incident with this level of
entanglement i don't know if i could fix
it
if we're not giving up who said anything
about giving up
standby
once the zero point starts to blow
there's no going back
we've got portals not good those aren't
portals
reality is breaking down so
we should close them what do you think
yep gotcha we're on it
got it instability will get worse from
here
watch out for reality waves copy
we'll keep watch reality ways to change
anything
i'm a butterfly that was a big one
everything all right down there i'm a
butterfly now so
no
i guess you're up i'm gonna need you to
be my eyes and ears
and arms and legs you're gonna have to
close those portals
can you handle it of course you can
let's go
there is no way this is good but
it is beautiful good work
but i'm gonna need more time keep going
copy that i see three more portals but
that next one
is really far i wish we could
i can teleport get down
we're gonna need to find a way past the
hunters
actually never mind
you look amazing
portal
uh so the wolves are new right
whoa alternate realities are breaking
through
we got to keep moving
i feel like reality just doesn't like me
how are we looking up there it's too
much
you have to keep going we've only got
one left
hold on
we got company
thank you for those reality waves right
about now
uh well done
that's the last one i think we got it
that's intense
okay this next
uh everything okay up there it's not
enough
i can't stop it but i might be able to
contain the blast
you must be stealing yourself
you don't have to do this
you're not leaving until this is done he
needs our help
come on
[Music]
we won't get another chance you need to
seal off the zero point and overload the
device
overload the device i'll be trapped in
the loop
we'll both have to find our way back no
matter what happens
do not give up i will find you
and you will tell me everything you
have my word here
no matter how isolated we are there is a
primal
force that binds us all that drives us
to adapt to journey forth in search of
adventure
[Music]
to never ever give up
to face our deepest fears no matter the
consequences
to confront the darkness that lurks
within
that primal force demands balance
[Music]
the island has grown wild and so
must you
you